wir brauchen eine Aufarbeitung der
gesamten corona-krise und der
corona-maßnahmen mir geht es nicht so
sehr um den Begriff Schuld das kann man
definieren wie man will aber es geht mir
darum dass man sagt es sind Fehler
gemacht worden also das müsste
eingestanden werden in gewissen Umfang
und es müsste dann auch eingestanden
werden dass man über das Ziel
hinausgeschossen ist dass man auch in
eine Art Kollektivismus verfallen ist in
dem kritische Stimmen kein Gehirn mehr
finden konnten das müsste dann auch dazu
führen in zweiter Linie dass man sagt
wie können wir diese Fehler nicht mehr
machen bzw vermeiden beim nächsten Mal
das ist soweit kommt also das wäre mir
entscheidend
dass man irgendwie sagen kann für einen
kommende Krise wir werden nicht wieder
so weit in in diese in diese
ja in diese missliche Lage hineinkommen
sondern können das irgendwie vermeiden
bedeutet das dass es für sie mit einem
Schuldeingeständnis mit einer
Entschuldigung getan wäre oder was
fordern Sie konkret in Sachen
Aufarbeitung es geht mir nicht so sehr
um die Worte also da wird dann gerungen
darum hat irgendjemand jetzt schuldge
das Wort Schuld in die Begriff genommen
oder nicht dann muss es muss aber
eingestanden werden es ist etwas schief
gelaufen es ist etwas falsch gelaufen da
kann man immer noch drüber diskutieren
wer daran Schuld ist aber aber es sind
Fehler gemacht worden von Institutionen
von verschiedenen Organisationen auch
von Parteien von Politikern von
einzelnen aber auch von von Gruppen und
und das das wäre mir wichtig und dann zu
sagen wie können wir das Vertrauen was
dadurch verloren gegangen ist wieder
herstellen und wie können wir
sicherstellen im Rahmen des Möglichen
dass das beim nächsten Mal nicht wieder
so passiert das nächste Mal steht quasi
schon fast vor der Tür der
Gesundheitsminister sagt ja Weihnachten
alle Ruhe geben Vorsicht Vorsicht
beobachtet Kinder noch einmal in die
Themen rein die besonders schmerzhaft
die besonders schwierig für uns auch als
Gesellschaft wo sehen Sie das größte
versagen wo sind die Stellen wo wir
wirklich sagen müssen da ist etwas
schiefgelaufen und wir haben es schon
gestriffen hier dieses Thema aber da
möchte immer tiefer reingehen wo es
etwas schief gelaufen wo ist wirklich
etwas passiert dass wir so nicht stehen
lassen können ja vor allem bei der
Zukunft unseres Landes bei den Kindern
wir sehen ja jetzt dass viele Kinder
durch diese lockdowns leider keine
sozialen Kontakte mehr haben sozial
inkompetent geworden sind Waschzwang
Übergewicht natürlich wegen mangelnden
Sport dann sind wir jetzt RSV Viren die
immer weiter sich etablieren bei den
Kindern weil die wohl durch das Maske
tragen durch zu wenig soziale Kontakte
wurden schlechtes Immunsystem haben und
keine keine im Gedächtnis aufgebaut
haben und natürlich auch Depressionen
teilweise Drogenkonsum ist massiv
gestiegen nicht nur in Deutschland auch
in Österreich sondern in der Schweiz und
es sind Kollateralschäden die werden uns
Jahre begleiten dass die jungen Kinder
auch keine Bildung genießen konnten
keine Kultur genießen konnten den fehlt
einfach ein Doppel 39 Wochen hatten wir
Lockdown in den Schulen die haben 39
Wochen keinen Schulunterricht gehabt
ihre Freunde nicht gesehen und bei denen
ist es halt ein größerer Anteil an ihre
gesamte Lebenszeit als bei uns ist
unverzeihlich aber fordert jemand hier
einen Rücktritt zum Beispiel von
jemandem mehr als eine
entschuldigungsuntersuchungsausstellung
hören
all diese Dinge
aufarbeiten aber die sitzen aus sie
sitzen es aus bis zum Ende die müssen
alle zurücktreten und auch haftbar
gemacht werden und eine Entschuldigung
wie ich entspannen das reicht nicht der
müsste eigentlich fast Gericht kommen
müssen das alles aufarbeiten Frieden zu
stiften in der Bevölkerung und genau das
gleiche bei Lauterbach Lauterbach mit so
vielen Punkten falsch und trotzdem hat
er nicht den Anstand zu sagen okay Leute
ich lieg falsch ich bin seit überfordert
ich trete zurück und mache jemand
anderen Platz die Bevölkerung würde das
begrüßen und wird auch wieder Vertrauen
in die Politik gewinnen momentan sich
nur dass es immer extremer wird in der
Gesellschaft
also das sehe ich als besonderes Problem
dass man nämlich in der in der gerade in
den letzten anderthalb Jahren etwa immer
stärker ein ein narrativ durch die Krise
getragen hat was überhaupt nicht mehr
begründet war und was ein bestimmten
Punkt auch für jeden oder die jeweiligen
großen Teil der Bevölkerung klar wurde
das ist doch nicht mehr begründet in der
Sache sondern einfach nur Maßnahmen die
einfach da sind lauter aber hat auch mal
irgendwann gesagt ja das ist ebenso und
und also an der Stelle muss man sein das
ist gefährlich für einen Demokratie
Flugzeug und Bahn z.B ich bin mir sicher
hätte man die Politiker im Zug erwischen
ohne Maske dann hätten wir im Zug jetzt
keine maskenpflicht und das kann man
auch kaum mehr erklären ich bin jetzt
hier auch in Berlin mit der mit der Bahn
gefahren ja also ich meine der hält sich
ja keiner mehr irgendwo wirklich dran
auch der Kontrolle nachgefragt weil wir
einfach wissen es macht keinen Sinn ich
glaube die Realität ist eine ganz andere
wie die in der Politik Blase was kommt
da mal ins Rollen ja was glaubst Du
Untersuchungsausschuss hat mir bereits
angesprochen aber das vermutlich nicht
geben das wäre wichtig in
Untersuchungsausschuss mich hat wenn man
das einmal noch mal vielleicht zusammen
nehmen und wir sehen ja auch wie sich
eine gewisse gesellschaftliche
Debattenkultur jetzt auch wandelt
doch erstaunt wie leichtfertig viele
viele Menschen in diesem Land
eigentlich ganz normal hingenommen haben
das Freiheitsrechte eingeschränkt wurden
das war etwas was mich fasziniert hat im
negativen Sinne in den Jahren 2020 2021
und auch in diesem Jahr noch zu Beginn
des Jahres das eigentlich eine Debatte
darüber nur stattgefunden hat mit
zwischen jedem die versucht haben
möglichst viele Freiheitsrechte zu
verteidigen und die dann sich dauernd
attackieren lassen mussten in zum Teil
wirklich Wüsten schimpftiraten als jene
die überhaupt nicht begriffen hätten
worum es bei diesem Virus geht und da
ähm habe ich den Eindruck tut sich jetzt
doch in gewisser Weise etwas dass
diejenigen die für diese
freiheitsrechtliche kämpft haben in
gewisser Weise doch mehr Zuspruch
bekommen zumindest für sich auch in
Anspruch nehmen können dass die
Argumentation
durchaus auch mit Blick auf die
vergangenen zweieinhalb Jahre die
richtige Argumentation war
auch argumentiert entschuldige mich da
einmal reingehen genau sie sie haben von
erster Stunde an Kritik geübt sie haben
da für ihren Job verloren haben sie eine
Entschuldigung bekommen hat sich Markus
Söder bei ihnen entschuldigt also ich
habe den den die Position im Edeka
verloren
weiterhin Professor in der Uni München
im Ethiker der also nein bei mir hat
sich niemand persönlich entschuldigt
also auch wie also wieder persönlich
noch ein unpersönliches das nicht
gegeben
aber sie haben ganz schön was aushalten
müssen sie wurden öffentlich dafür
deformiert kann man sagen ja das ist
wahr und zwar das muss man schon sagen
nicht nur von einer Seite sondern auch
von Teilen der Medien
nicht anwesenden Teil der Medien von
anderen
Mitgliedern aus meiner Community
sozusagen auch und eben von der von der
staatlichen Seite ja also es ist zwar es
kam einiges zusammen und das ist also
man könnte es auch jetzt sagt ne ja und
da kann niemand mal auf sie zu und hat
gesagt entschuldigen
ich war da so gefangen ich sie hatten da
recht an dem und dem Punkt das hatte ich
gar nicht so gesehen dass war ich nicht
informiert genug wusste ich nicht besser
so also naja ich höre jetzt so im Laufe
der letzten Monate von vielen Bekannten
aus dem beruflichen oder privaten Umfeld
dass die eigentlich wir haben ja immer
zugestimmt
und man hat es natürlich damals nicht so
gesagt ich meine das ist mir auch ist
mir wichtiger als wenn man es nicht
sagen will ist besser als gar nicht aber
ich glaube es ist schon schon wichtig
dass wir auch jetzt gerade für junge
Menschen dass wir darauf dass wir sie
dazu erziehen auch etwas gegen den
Mainstream zu sagen und und gegen
Strömung ich glaube dass das war doch
eigentlich immer auch in den früheren
Generation wichtig übrigens noch
Entschuldigung ja ein weiteren Bereich
den man auch nicht außer Acht lassen
sollte die Justiz hat ja auch teilweise
mitgespielt also natürlich großen Teil
ja klar ich weiß nicht was man da machen
kann aber das scheint ja irgendwie auch
eine ment qualitätssache zu sein man
kann ja die Justiz jetzt nicht es wird
schwierig die zu verklagen ja aber ich
fand das erschreckend das ist ja so ich
meine wenn ich mir vorstelle ich bin
überzeugt dass meine Position richtig
ist und ich mache nichts kriminelles
dann wieder Rückhalt von den Medien noch
von der Politik und dann schließlich
auch nicht mal von der Justiz zu
bekommen wobei da muss man
Einschränkungen machen glaube ich es gab
immer wieder gesagt haben z.B das
böllerverbot dann war nicht rechten ja
das kannst
richtig ja die Leute die im Park von der
Parkbank fahren
um Gottes Willen nicht die ganze Justiz
jetzt fahren aber das ist doch auch so
eine Mentalitätsfrage was geht denn
davor in der Justiz und die Urteile
waren ja oft so dass sie einfach nur
gesagt haben dass er hat ja gesagt und
wenn das sagt brauchen wir uns damit
nicht weiter zu beschäftigen aber das
ist doch genau die Aufgabe der Justiz in
der Fragen also genau auf Seite des
Bürgers zu sein und zu gucken ob der
Staat in das richtig und die
Verhältnismäßigkeit natürlich können Sie
eigentlich einmal sagen was der
Ausschlag war dass sie ausgetreten sind
oder dass sie in den Gremium nicht mehr
angepasst war genau das Ausschlaggebende
Momentum ich bin ja nicht ausgetreten
gehen
Punkt ja ich bekam ja einen schreiben
seinerzeit also im Februar 2021 Mitglied
im bayerischen eingetragen genau
der neu gegründet war gerade erst im im
Ende 2020 und wir haben erst einmal
gesagt gehabt damals und ich bekam dann
ein Brief von der bayerischen
tatskanzlei in dem äh ich weiß nicht
mitgeteilt wurde dass ich nicht weil
länger in diesem Edeka bin aber das war
ohne Begründung aber gar nicht so und
ähm ist es wurde dann später gesagt dass
ich überhaupt hätte ich würde für den
gesamten Ethikrat sprechen was ich nicht
getan habe und was man sogar im
Fernseher Ausschnitten wo ich wieder
ziemlich äußere auch sieht dass das
nicht stimmt
und aber es war eindeutig hatte mich
kritisch gegen mit dem Lockdown geäußert
auch über gegenüber seerokovic das habe
ich vor kürzlich noch mal auf Twitter
auch noch mal mit großer Resonanz noch
mal zurückgeholt sozusagen aus der
Vergangenheit das war diese Kritik an
den an diesen Konzepten die
offensichtlich politisch nicht genehmbar
zu der Zeit jedenfalls Friedrich was war
da los was war mit vielen von uns los
was war
los der
geglaubt haben gefolgt haben und dass
wir wenig hinterfragt haben und dass der
Graben über den gesprochen entstehen
konnte überhaupt dass die die
hinterfragt haben zumindest kritisch bei
euch wurden wie konnte es so weit kommen
wir sind alle selbstständig Denken der
Menschen ja nicht mehr es war Angst und
natürlich Propaganda und auch Angst das
Rückgrat zu haben vielleicht gegen den
Mainstream gegen das narrativ das zu
sagen weil man Angst hatte dann
stigmatisiert diffamiert zu werden und
sogar entlassen zu werden und es war
tatsächlich eine Art Massenpsychose weil
natürlich kann man die Gesundheit die
überhöht dargestellt wurden moralisch
natürlich nicht in Frage stellen weil
dann ist man ja gleich irgendwie in der
Schublade gesteckt wurden weil es geht
um Gesundheit man muss ja sozusagen mit
funktionieren und deswegen war es eine
massenformation und eine Massenpsychose
ausgelöst durch ständige trompedierung
mit Propaganda mit Schlagzeilen mit
inzidenzzahlen die Menschen hatten
einfach Angst und dadurch sind auch
Psychosen entstanden und viele Menschen
jetzt im Nachhinein auch spreche auch
Journalisten Politiker die sagen ja ich
hatte zwar schon komisches Bauchgefühl
eine andere Meinung aber ich hatte Angst
die zu äußern weil ich dann
diskreditiert worden wäre deswegen gab
es auch keinen Pluralismus mehr und
keine Debattenkultur mehr die wurde
beerdigt und der Diskurs von dem er die
Demokratie de facto lebt wurde begraben
und daran leidet unsere Gesellschaft
erst heute dass ich natürlich schweren
Widerspruch bei Ihnen vielleicht nein
wir haben natürlich das erlebt hier als
journalistenbild und in unserem Verlag
gibt es ein weiteres Medium die Welt wir
waren da glaube ich relativ ähnlich
unterwegs aber wir haben natürlich
gespürt dass die Meinungen die wir auch
vertreten haben die Berichte die
Beiträge die wir gesendet haben oder
auch geschrieben haben natürlich sehr
sehr kritisch von nicht nur Politikern
sondern auch anderen Kollegen anderer
Medien beugt wurden das ist vollkommen
richtig also da stand man schon in einer
Ecke in die man reingedrängt wurde und
das war die Ecke die nicht zu den oder
wie gehört nicht zu den ist einfach
andere Regierung sprechen das ist
vollkommen richtig gab genug andere
Journalisten die sich als Regierung
Sprecher aufführten ja auch zum Teil die
bevöl beschimpft haben quasi mit der
Zeigefinger also quasi die Arbeit
eigentlich von vielen Minister und der
Bundeskanzlerin übernommen haben das
haben wir in der Tat nicht gemacht
deswegen widerspreche ich in dem Punkt
ganz deutlich es gab eine Debattenkultur
sie war möglicherweise nicht so
ausgeprägt dass man sich gegenseitig
zugehört hat sondern man hat sich
wahrscheinlich eher beschimpft oder
zugemacht und das eine Ohr reinlaufen
lassen
es gab einen Kollegen von der Welt ich
glaube Olaf der Mann der hat jeden Tag
die inzidenzzahlen getwittert und hat
immer wieder gewarnt mit erhobenen
Zeigefinger was wir machen müssen und da
war schon einer aus sozusagen aus ihrem
Stall der jeden Tag eigentlich Panik
geschnitten mit Zahlen die die Menschen
dann auch erschreckt haben wo sie Angst
haben um Gottes Willen irgendwie 10.000
Seiten natürlich klar
schon deutlich und aber das ist also ich
möchte genauso wenig dass wir die die
das begleitet haben mit dem erhoben mit
dem wir selber werden
wir hier in unserem Tischchen um auch
genau das zu tun ich frage mich nur Herr
Rupprecht wie sehen sie dass wir reden
hier gerade über die Aufarbeitung
manchmal habe ich das Gefühl viele sagen
jetzt auch Aufarbeitung auf aber es
bringt mir eine Entschuldigung ich
möchte jetzt endlich das Wort Pandemie
nicht mehr hören ich möchte jetzt zurück
in die Normalität wie es ihr Gespür für
dieses Thema brauchen die Menschen eine
Entschuldigung brauchen sie etwas das
klar macht es wurden Fehler gemacht oder
wollen viele jetzt einfach sagen lass
mich in Ruhe jetzt möchte ich einfach
meine Lieben
ich kann es nicht wirklich wiedergeben
aber nichts ist ähm kommt später umso
stärker hervor als unterdrückte
Emotionen und diese Emotionen werden
Leben lang da sein und das was den
Leuten angetan wurde die da anderer
Meinung waren damals so Beginn der
coronazeit und durch die ganze Zeit
durch das war schon schlimm und das kann
einfach so nicht stehen bleiben wenn das
unge aufgearbeitet stehen bleibt dann
ich weiß nicht wozu das für die Spaltung
bleibt dann letztendlich bestehen auch
wenn man es übertönen nicht also das
muss aufgearbeitet werden und der erste
Schritt ist nun mal eine Entschuldigung
weil diese Maßnahmen eben übergriffig
waren einfach ja also ich denke schon
dass das sein muss also weil wer muss
sich da entschuldigen das Problem ist
Chefin der letzten Bundesregierung die
ist im Ruhestand ja warum können sie
trotzdem in der Tat aber es hat
natürlich irgendwie keine Konsequenz
weil sie haben vollkommen recht eine
Entschuldigung wäre angebracht von ihr
nicht nur bei dem Thema da gibt's auch
noch andere politische Themen die immer
einfallen mit Blick auf die Ukraine und
Russland aber ähm es ist dann eine
Entschuldigung gut aber es kam immer
sagen was haben die Schulkinder davon
die jetzt wie sie sagen oder Depression
leiden davon alleine
Heilung wir müssen heilen wir müssen
gucken wir müssen ja anfangen uns zu
verzeihen gegenseitig beide Seiten und
es geht nur wenn jemanden ersten Schritt
macht und Entschuldigung ist der erste
Schritt in juristische Aufarbeitung ist
der zweite Schritt ich glaube es ist
sehr schwierig immer zu sagen wie ich
muss jetzt der andere muss jetzt das und
das tun musst jetzt nicht sagen ich es
tut mir leid ich ich habe Schuld auf
mich geladen und sowas ist glaube ich
schwierig aber was man schon glaube tun
könnte ist den Baum tun wir das
eigentlich wir wollen die Fehler beim
nächsten Mal vermeiden das ist doch der
Punkt
lernen daraus viel viel wichtiger zu
gucken was es schief gelaufen was war
richtig und ich glaube festzuhalten
bleibt auf die Freiheit zu setzen ist am
Ende auch nach dieser Pandemie extrem
richtig und wichtig gewesen immer wieder
ganz massiv zu hinterfragen warum wird
diese Freiheit wieder eingeschränkt ist
das wirklich nötig sie einzuschränken
weil die Folgen von eingeschränkter
Freiheit sind dramatisch erkennbar